there are some corner cases where you
don't even leave your bedroom without a
patent attorney you know particularly in
the life sciences of segment where
patents are worth anything and
everything there are other segments like
the web where you know Mark Zuckerberg
and Facebook it's not about the idea at
all it's about the execution and if you
think you're the smartest guy on the
planet or woman on the planet and you
you could not use any feedback then just
start coding in you have a great time
the odds are you're probably not
Zuckerberg or Steve Jobs and you really
might want to have some iteration of
feedback before you actually spend the
time coding or building hardware or or
doing both and so this is a real
trade-off between how much do I share of
my idea to get feedback and how much do
I want to keep this per character when I
teach this class for the National
Science Foundation when they are rails
at rocket scientists and they have real
technical ideas even they get it the
idea of getting out of the building is
not about you talking it's not about you
sharing your source code or your IP or
your license or your patents it's about
you listening and for an entrepreneur
listening is a very hard one and earn
skill is that I want to tell you enough
so I could get you to kind of understand
that what I'm asking about but I'm not
telling you about the details of my
product and and that's what's kind of
hard for people to understand